qu'ils auront jusqu'à deux ans
de sursis.
- Ici, il faut faire
une clôture qui va avoir
environ 40 pieds de long.
- La sécurité de la piscine
creusée d'André St-Hilaire
sera jugée non conforme
à partir du 1er juillet 2023.
- Je n'ai pas vraiment le choix
ici avec l'aménagement
de ma cour d'y aller avec
une clôture additionnelle.
- Un règlement du gouvernement
du Québec oblige tous
les propriétaires de piscine
à rendre leur plan d'eau
inacessible à un enfant en bas
âge depuis la résidence.
C'est la fin d'un droit
acquis pour les installationsss
construites avant 2010 dans
le but d'éviter des noyades.
- L'enjeu est très financier.
- Le pompier à la retraite
constate que la facture explose.
- Les soumissions que j'ai eues,
il y a des gens qui m'ont di
"T'aurais fait faire ça voilà
deux puis ça t'aurait coûté
peut-être 4000." En avril,
le coût est maintenent
rendu de 9200 dollars.
- Le fabricant et installateur
Clôtures Daviault est aux
premières loges de la flambée
des prix des matières premières,
comme l'acier et de la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre.
LAURENT DAVIAULT
Clôtures Daviault
- À cause de la loi,
la demande, elle a augmenté.
Le cocktail est parfait, là.
Les prix ont vraiment doublé
depuis un an et demi environ.
- Radio-ppris que
le contexte économique force la
main de la ministre des Affaires
municipales et de l'Habitation,
Andrée Laforest.
Donc de plus de deux ans.
RAYNALD HAWKINS, d. g.
Société ge du Québec
- On repousse encore
une échéance. Les coroners
nous disent : "Pratiquement
neuf fois sur dix,
les noyades ont eu lieu dans
ines résidentielles."
- Une pétition en ligne
ayant recueilli près
de 14 000 signatures demande
rnement de transférer
l'obligation aux futurs
propriétaires.
- À chaque foishaque foishaque n
peut amener une sécurité
additionnelle par une
réglementation, j'en suis pas
contre, mais il faut quand même
qu'il y ait une aide qui vienne
les propriétaires.
- Une telle aide,
comme un crédit d'impôt,
pourrait néanmoins créer
une injustice pour ceux qui
ont déjà réalisé les trava